hi everyone this is my first Pi data so
I'm uh super excited to be here
um I'm going to be speaking about cause
reasoning and Bayesian inference
so if any of you are interested in
following up in more detail I've got a
repo for the talk uh which you can go
and find here
and because I was actually super
productive and got more work done than I
thought this talk is also a package
announcement so great news
so I am Ben Vincent I grew up in uh
Cambridge England and I've been living
in Scotland now for uh some time
I have just come out or 15 years in
Academia and now I have an industry
position and so I've completed what
could be called the the golden tetrad
uh for a little while now I've been
contributing to open source with the uh
Pi MC Bayesian library and I've been
doing uh Consulting work with pymc labs
now you may have heard that uh causal
inference is so hot right now and if you
haven't hopefully this talk will uh
convey why that might be the case
but as a good ex-academic and data
scientist I thought that it would be
good to evidence this claim with some
data so I typed in cause or inference
into Google Trends and after initially
getting excited about a a peak in
interest in recent times I realized that
this was actually due to a change in
data collection methodology
but if you squint and step back from the
screen you can see that there might be a
slight slope here but is it convincingly
there or not
so it was time to break out some
statistics
so I ran a simple linear regression with
a dummy variable for this change in data
collection methodology and the important
uh result here is that we got a
significant uh slope
and what this allows me to say roughly
is if we theoretically ran this
experiment an infinite number of times
there is a five percent there's a less
than five percent chance that the test
statistic would be
um as Extreme as The observed test
statistic and that there in one sentence
is why I'm not a frequentist
so as a good Bayesian I did the same
thing but with a Bayesian model using pi
MC and the result is pretty much the
same but now on the right hand side you
can see that we get a posterior
distribution over this slope so if I
asked myself is this slope positive then
the answer seems to be convincingly yes
but I can answer that using uh more
straightforward language saying that I'm
94 confident that the true increase in
interest in causal inference is roughly
between 0.03 and 0.08 units per month
and I can hear the skeptical among you
saying
um Ben that doesn't really justify
causal inference being
um so hot right now and you might be
right you might think uh well it's
lukewarm
but the but the Google Trends is a
lagging indicator what about the uh the
future
if we do some Googling we can see that
Gartner have placed causal AI right at
the start of the uh the hype cycle
and
if you don't know the reasons why then
hopefully I can convey uh why there's a
lot of interest in uh causal inference
causal reasoning
um at this point
and in order to do that we have to think
a little bit about the difference
between statistical relationships and
causal relationships
statistical relationships are generally
quite easy to establish
observational data are pretty much
sufficient we've got a really broad
range of statistical and machine
learning approaches available and
because of that we've got a lot of
expertise in the data science Community
to establish statistical relationships
on the other hand establishing causal
relationships is very hard it often but
as we'll see later on it doesn't always
require uh randomized control trials or
experiments
but I think at this point there is much
less expertise in the data science
community and it also requires much more
care to be taken
when you're examining statistical
relationships a typical approach might
create a descriptive model where you
essentially take in a bunch of predictor
values and you pass this through some
possibly complicated Black Box function
in order to get your predicted output
whereas uh when you take a more causal
approach you try to make a more open box
model where the causal relationships
have directionality and the details
Inside the Box
um really matter
now statistical relationships
um establishing statistical
relationships is and I think always will
be very useful because it allows you to
predict things and a lot of us uh data
scientists spend a lot of our time doing
prediction and that's going to carry on
being useful
however the concern from the the causal
side of things is that
if we make an intervention in our system
if someone goes in and changes how
something works then potentially your
predictive model could could break
catastrophically
if you have taken a causal approach to
modeling then hopefully you are at a
much lower risk of that happening
and so you should hopefully if all works
out well be in a better position to
answer questions where interventions are
made so you should hopefully be able to
ask what-if questions like what if the
UK had not voted for brexit that's
something that happened in the past or
you could say what if I half my
advertising budget next year
now to flesh this out in a little bit
more detail we're going to look at a
um miniature simulation that I ran uh
where
um as a British person it had to be
about tea and so we were interested in
um a possible causal relationship
between tea and death
so I simulated
um an admittedly silly example
where we uh I simulated 5 000 people and
we look at which of those people drank
tea and which of them uh died during the
simulation period and what we see is
that of the people who died a very large
proportion of them drag t
and so if we look at this statistical
relationship with derived from
observational data this would be really
concerning
um if I hadn't simulated the data of
course and we might think uh people
should stop drinking tea
but then um to make the point in my
little simulated world I conducted a
randomized control trial sometimes known
as an A B test
and in this version of the experiment
again with 5000 simulated people I
randomly assigned them to drink tea or
to not drink tea and I saw who died and
who didn't die
and in this case uh roughly the same
number of people ended up dying but what
we can see is that if anything T might
actually have a mildly protective effect
because
um of the people who died most of them
actually did not drink tea
so this is uh
very confusing why is this the case
first we think that t might kill people
and now we think that t might have a
protective effect
well that's because I created a
contrived example where there was a
confounding variable of age
so in my simulation
older people are more likely to drink
tea
older people are more likely to die
because of that the people who died tend
to be those who drink tea
but that is purely observational and we
can't make a uh causal Claim about that
but if I come along now and do my uh
random assignments what we do is we
break the relationship between age and T
and so the probability that anyone would
drink tea is now entirely up to me as an
experimenter
I'm making an intervention
and this is exactly the case that could
be problematic if we just look at
statistical relationships
now even though random assignment is
really good and really useful it doesn't
overcome death and so it is still the
older people who end up dying
and so in this simulation now what it
looks like uh mirrors the actual reality
of what I simulated in my contrived
World in that t had a mildly protective
effect
now you could say Okay
um randomization is great you've
convinced me of that but we are data
scientists we're not um we're not
scientists uh in uh University
so can we not kind of solve this by
modeling by doing clever modeling
and the answer to that is yes kind of
so if you think about your problem of
tea and mortality rates and you think
hard and you think that age might be a
confounder I'm going to take this into
account and I'm going to measure it in
my study you could then create a
Bayesian model which reflects this uh
story of the data
and if you do that you find that you can
correctly infer that t has a mildly
protective effect
um in this made up data set
so that's great that's good news can we
just do modeling rather than experiments
well the answer to that
um depends and it depends on whether we
have actually captured the full story of
the data the full data generating
process
in this example we fixed our problem by
taking into account our confounding
variable of age but in real examples
there might be many more confounding
variables and the story of the data
might be much more complex and the
concern is that you never know if you
have um the correct or an accurate story
of the data in mind when you model it
and that is why
randomization is so effective
randomization and a b tests should
always be the first Port of Call if you
want to make causal relationships
if you want to make causal claims
the problem though is that you can't
always randomize and this is a problem
for a number of different reasons
um a big one is that randomized
controlled trials can be costly so both
in terms of uh money but also in terms
of time and they can often require very
large sample sizes
and all of these things together
actually combine in a slightly negative
way to create uh vested interests which
might subtly bias the outcome especially
if um uh profit is involved for example
or
um scientific kudos
another reason why randomized control
trials
um might be might be difficult to do is
um ethics it's not always ethically uh
okay to assign people to conditions that
you think might uh harm them and in fact
even the opposite You could argue that
it's ethically problematic to not assign
people to to conditions that
um could benefit them
also randomization can sometimes be
impossible
sometimes just because
um the data that you have collected uh
was actually collected in the past by
other people who didn't use random
assignment but sometimes
um you just can't randomize for example
which individuals are exposed to
um linear TV advertising for example
and so
if our boss comes to us and says hey I
heard that causal inference is so hot
right now uh I would like you to infer
the causal relationship of
um last year's advertising Budget on uh
customer sign ups
um you might be tempted to hold your
head in your hands
um and possibly resign because you can't
do a uh randomized control trial in this
situation and you know about all the
problems of confounding variables uh and
more so what should we do should we cry
or quit
absolutely not we should instead uh go
and buy a coffee and a copy of
quasi-experimentation by Charles S
reichardt
quite eye experiments um there's a whole
family of quasi-experiments and these
basically outline a whole set of
different designs and corresponding
analyzes which can be used in different
situations that you might find yourself
in depending for example if you have
many repeated observations over time
like um like sales over time or if you
do or don't have uh control units for
example
so this is uh cool this is great we can
go and read this book and
um get to work
the problem is
um
quasi-experimentation and the analysis
of the data is uh new to a lot of people
so wouldn't it be really useful and
really great if there was a python
package which could help us with this
task
um fear not there is so
um today I I'm doing an announcement of
the the causal Pi package so you can go
and check out the the repo
so as I say we have a GitHub repository
we have some uh docs
um
so it's good we would like people to go
and check it out and give us some
feedback
but we also have a number of uh issues
we're at a very early release and so uh
do not put this in your production code
at this point
so at this point you might be asking uh
what does causal Pi do
um so I'm going to show you a worked
example of uh of making a causal claim
in a quasi-experimental situation
and something that plays um on people's
minds very often is what was the causal
impact of brexit uh many claims were
made by
um both sides of the argument and
continued to be made and so wouldn't it
be great if we could empirically
evaluate the effects upon the UK's GDP
um that happened after uh brexit
now this is uh fundamentally a
counterfactual question because what we
have to do is we we can compare the the
UK's GDP with the counterfactor of what
would have been the UK's GDP had the
referendum vote gone the other way
now I don't have a time machine or
access to parallel universes to go and
get that data and so we have a
fundamental problem here of how do we
get a comparison
um and this is what
um quasi-experiments can help with
so practically in causal Pi you start by
importing the package of course
and
um you can import uh GDP data so this is
uh this is actually available real GDP
data that I've got off of a an economist
friends
um so you can download that data set and
play with it after some uh very simple
uh pandas manipulation what we end up
with is a a data frame of GDP for a
whole bunch of different countries uh
more than I could fit on the screen uh
over time
and this is expressed in units of
um billions of US dollars
if we plot this
what we can do in order to make it uh
meaningful is we can plot this in
comparison to the when the referendum
vote announced so the gdps of all of
these countries was normalized to 100 at
that point so the big red line shows
what actually happened to the UK's GDP
and we can see that before the
referendum uh the growth in GDP was
roughly in the middle of the pack
compared to the other countries
after GDP sorry after the referendum uh
was uh the vote was announced we can see
that
um just visually we're maybe at the the
bottom of the pack
so we also have other things that
happened which
um is worth bearing in mind that people
might want to ask me about at the end
um so we've got a whole bunch of data
but what do we not have on this graph
what we do not have is data from the
parallel universe the counter factual of
what would have happened to the UK's GDP
if the referendum vote had gone uh the
other way
and
that is uh solved or one approach to
doing that to estimating the counter
factual is given by uh a method called
synthetic control
and it does exactly what it says so we
don't have a control UK which is similar
in all ways to the UK other than it
didn't vote for brexit so we're going to
create a synthetic control UK
and we do that by
um estimating it as a weighted sum a
weighted combination of the control
countries
um that we have before the referendum so
the uh the training data
and the second thing that we're going to
do is to create our synthetic control so
that might be uh the the Blue Line we're
going to use the weightings that we
estimated before in order to generate
our synthetic uh GDP prediction
and just to be really clear this is um
some kind of psychic learn type of uh
syntax what you could do if you have a a
weighted sum model what you're doing is
you're you're fitting these weightings
based upon the the training data or the
data you have before the intervention
before the brexit vote
then in order to create the counter
factual you're using that same model
with the same weightings in order to
predict what the the UK's GDP would have
been based upon the training data of
other countries
and by doing this comparison now you can
estimate uh the causal impact of brexit
the next step is to create a model
formula so some people might be quite
familiar with this but all it really
says is that we want to model the UK GDB
column
given the data that we have about all
the other countries GDP
we can call the synthetic control method
from uh
causal pie and we've got this pretty
simple API here where we provide the the
data we provide the treatment time we
provide the model formula that I just
um outlined and we also provide a a
model to to do the estimation with some
parameters that don't really matter in
our case
I should say that
um if you're interested in causal
inference but you don't know about uh
Bayesian inference then
causal Pi allows you to use traditional
ordinary least squares model fitting
approaches currently using scikit-learn
models but today I'm going to talk about
using pi MC models to do Bayesian
inference in in this causal setting
so once you've run that you might be
interested in visualizing the outputs
with this very handy plot function
and that gives you a graph and a nice
figure or I think it's quite nice I hope
I hope you do as well
what we can see
at the top left we can see that the uh
the Shaded region here this is our uh
model fit so the synthetic control we
can see uh pre-intervention is actually
a very good fit to the data and we're
getting an r squared estimate of uh 0.96
which is pretty good
so that allows us to say that
it's a reasonable proposition to model
the UK as a weighted sum of a bunch of
other countries
what we also get is an estimate of the
counterfactual so this is
um
something that you can only obtain if
you can travel into the parallel
universe where the brexit vote went the
other way but this is our estimate of
that along with credible intervals
if we look at the the difference between
the two that allows us to estimate the
uh the impact on GDP
the middle plot shows exactly the same
data but now we're visualizing it in a
different way
um plusing the residuals which hopefully
make that a little bit clearer to see
and in the bottom panel we can see the
cumulative causal impact so for some of
you who are familiar with other packages
this has some similarities
but if we look at our estimate we can
basically say
uh with 94 uh confidence we think that
the cumulative effect of brexit is
somewhere between about
-3 and about minus five uh billion US
dollars
and then you can say well is that a
large amount of money or a small amount
of money how does that compare to the
promises of the uh leave and the uh
remain campaigns and hopefully
uh keep people accountable
but of course
um I've been suggesting that things are
incredibly simple and that's not
necessarily the case so uh there is some
more due diligence that you have to do
um that don't quite have time for here
now causal Pi has a bunch of other
features which I'll quickly talk about
um you can use this in interrupted time
series which is very similar to
synthetic control but in the example
that we want to know uh how many excess
deaths was caused by kobit 19 in England
and Wales we can do a very similar thing
this is different from synthetic control
because we don't have
um untreated units to do the same
approach but nevertheless we can still
use
interrupted time series to come up with
an estimate
and
um this is done with standardized units
so the result here of about 20 is not 20
people that's uh on a standardized scale
we can also do the regression
discontinuity design so on the right
hand side we see
all cause mortality in America as a
function of age
and one of the we're in particular
looking at all cause mortality around
the age of 21 and that's particularly
relevant because that is the
um time where people become legally able
to drink
um and so there's a whole uh chain of
reasoning that allows you to essentially
say that if you look at the
discontinuity
um if there is one then this becomes
very similar to a randomized control
trial and in this case might allow you
to say that
um the mortality rate increases by
approximately seven
um per 100 000 I believe
another very popular
um quasi-experimental design is uh
differences in differences
um we don't have time to explain this
example but
um we we cover that
now I so far have maybe LED you to
believe that
quasi-experiments can solve all of your
causal inference problems and that is
very much not the case so if we start to
think about
um the story of some data of did your
advertising budget drive a causally
drive sales you can think well
ad exposure might causally influence uh
purchases
the problem is you didn't directly
expose adverts to people what you did
was uh set a defined budget and a
strategy which advertising channels did
you direct the money at
so you're not in control and you don't
necessarily know who is exposed to the
advert
you can also think of uh confounding
variables
so some people are more fundamentally
interested in purchasing your product
than other people and it could be that
you're advertising was targeted
specifically uh at those people
and then you can think further maybe
there's seasonality so this in fact
might be a confounder on a confounder
now the specific diagram that I've drawn
here isn't the relevant point the point
is that once you start uh building up a
causal story of your data you can see
how things get uh complicated very
quickly and so this is
um why making causal inference
especially in observational settings is
tricky
nevertheless
um when you can't randomize
quasi-experiments are very often uh your
friend
and we are releasing uh causal pi
in order to help with this so whether
you're uh happy with frequentist or
familiar with uh Bayesian approaches you
can analyze data you get from Quasar
experiments so if you're interested in
um how causal Pi evolves or you're
interested in causality in general and
Bayesian inference then feel free to
find me on Twitter
uh I also have a website and I'd invite
people to check out the repo we're very
interested in uh bug reports or feature
requests and if you're interested to see
how
um
uh causal inference and quasi
experiments might help you in an
industry setting feel very free to get
in touch
thanks yeah thank you very much Benjamin
that was a great presentation uh so
we've got a couple of questions on here
uh the first one uh by Francesco
as in models as in ml models data seems
to play an important role any suggested
resources for how to properly design
ROCT
um not of the top of my head so uh the
theory of doing randomized control
trials and a b tests is um kind of
relatively simple you just want to
randomize things but there I know that
there are a lot of um things that you
have to check for example that
um each of your individual treatment
units uh maybe people for example don't
communicate within each other so that
the assumptions of Independence and so
on are properly met but um off the top
of my head I'm afraid uh I don't I'll
I'll get in the chat after this
no worries at all and the next question
from
Emiliano
um why didn't you use diff Thief model
ah yeah so uh so you we we do uh we can
do difference in differences uh so I had
a slide on that
um now the the reason why I didn't do it
for the brexit example is because we do
have
um quite Rich time series data
so
um one of one of the things to be aware
of as well is that these methods
um aren't necessarily totally discreet
there there is some overlap between
these methods so um there's there is a
method called synthetic differences in
differences
uh for example
all right great but it does uh
interesting so the next one from
narender
um is the Wayne model basically training
uh ml model to predict the pre-treatment
GDP of the UK based on the pre-brexit
GDP of the other countries
that's right so you take the
um the GDP data of all the uh untreated
countries and you
uh that this was a really simple model
where basically
um models the synthetic control as a
weighted sum but you could have
um you could have more complex models to
do that but yeah what you've written in
the question is right sounds right
awesome awesome so the next person is
asking how to have an access to the
slides
um how would they be able to access the
slides if they want to do so
um I will try to make them available and
I'll uh I'll tweet it or tweet about it
I guess you said your handle earlier on
the on your slide yeah yeah I'll um I'll
go in the Discord after this as well
oh great yeah yeah the discussions goes
on from there as well so yeah
uh last question from
from David or
could you please tell me how is related
to the causal impact
in case you know it
yeah so
um
on uh we have a bit more information
about that on our GitHub page so
um it's uh it strongly overlaps with
causal impacts
um the difference with causal Pi is that
we aim to make this more General so
causal impact only uses
um it only targets synthetic control for
example
um and it it uses uh Bayesian structural
time series in order to do that but the
package that we've released now aims to
have a broader applicability across a
lot of other different Quasar
experimental methods
thanks for the question
awesome
um and finally
from William is interrupted time series
very similar in idea to regression
discontinuity
um yes so in answer to a previous
question I said how there's
um there's actually overlap between a
lot of these methods
um the way how I would say that
regression discontinuity is slightly
different from interrupted time series
because with regression discontinuity
you typically don't use time as your X
variable if you like that would tend to
be
um some other variable whether that be
age or for example spatial location
you could see how
um exposure to advertising varies across
borders of countries when different
legal regions for example